just coming up you know it is a happy
time but I'm sure melancholy time for
your family too is it sweeter with what
your family has been through with this
success you know obviously our
Christmases are yeah I mean they they
bring a lot of emotions to them a lot of
a lot of wonderful memories and you know
a lot of member a lot of emotions of God
we wish you know so many members of our
family were here but I'll tell you what
I mean we you know as a family you know
we get together and we we do have a fun
experience as a family we get all our
fights out hopefully on the first night
but you know it's it's it's totally the
all-american Christmas you know we do we
just get the family in and we let the
kids open one present on Christmas Eve
it wouldn't be Christmas without you
know getting in some traffic you know
the holiday stress you know where you
where you got to have a beer
mid-afternoon just to calm down you know
and and so so maybe a beer around noon
not mid-afternoon but anyways so we um
but we're excited about it it's gonna be
a it's going to be nice to to be home
it's will be this will be our second
Christmas in our home and and we're
still getting all the kinks worked out
to the house we were prematurely in our
home last Christmas we've been in that
you